et ce n'est qu'un seul site.
Un schéma similaire a été observé encore et encore
chaque fois que des vidéos de décapitation étaient révélées
au cours de la guerre en Irak.
Les réseaux sociaux ont rendu ces images plus accessibles que jamais,
mais si nous retournons encore un peu en arrière,
nous verrons que c'était la caméra
qui a, pour la première fois, attiré un nouveau type de foule
dans l'histoire des décapitations comme un spectacle public.
Dès que la caméra est apparue,
il y a une éternité, le 17 juin 1939,
elle a eu un effet immédiat et sans équivoque.
Ce jour-là a été créée, en France,
la première vidéo d'une décapitation publique.
C'était l'exécution à la guillotine
d'un tueur en série allemand, Eugen Weidmann,
à l'extérieur de la prison Saint-Pierre à Versailles.
Weidmann devait être exécuté au petit matin,
comme il était d'usage en ce temps-là,
mais son bourreau était nouveau dans le métier
et avait sous-estimé le temps nécessaire à sa préparation.
Weidmann a donc été exécuté à 4h30 du matin,
heure à laquelle, un matin de juin,
il y avait assez de lumière pour prendre des photos,
et un spectateur dans la foule a filmé l'événement,
à l'insu des autorités.
Plusieurs photographies ont également été prises,
et il est encore possible aujourd'hui de regarder le film en ligne
et de regarder les photos.
Le jour de l'exécution de Weidmann,
la presse décrivait la foule comme étant « répugnante » et « turbulente »
mais ce n'était rien comparé aux incalculables milliers de personnes
qui pouvaient alors étudier l'action
à loisir,
immortalisée dans le détail.
La caméra a peut-être rendu ces scènes plus accessibles que jamais auparavant,
mais il n'est pas uniquement question de la caméra.
Si nous retournons plus loin en arrière,
nous verrons que, depuis qu'il y a
des exécutions et décapitations judiciaires publiques,
il y a eu une foule pour les regarder.
A Londres, jusqu'au début du XIXème siècle,
il pouvait y avoir 4000-5000 personnes à regarder une pendaison classique.
Il pouvait y avoir 40 000-50 000 personnes à l'exécution d'un criminel connu.
Et une décapitation,
qui était un événement rare en Angleterre en ce temps-là,
attirait encore plus de gens.
En mai 1820,
cinq hommes connus comme les Conspirateurs de la Rue de Cato
ont été exécutés à Londres pour avoir prémédité
l'assassinat de membres du gouvernement britannique.
Ils ont été pendus puis décapités.
C'était une scène macabre.
Une par une, la tête de chacun des hommes a été tranchée et montrée à la foule.
Et 100 000 personnes,
c'est 10 000 de plus que ce que peut contenir le stade de Wembley,
étaient venues voir.
Les rues étaient bondées.
Les gens avaient loué des fenêtres et des toits.
Les gens dans les rues avaient escaladé des carrioles et des wagons.
Les gens escaladaient les lampadaires.
Des gens sont morts dans la cohue des jours d'exécutions.
Certains éléments nous portent à croire qu'au cours de notre histoire
de décapitations et d'exécutions publiques,
la vaste majorité des personnes à venir voir
sont soient enthousiastes ou, dans le meilleur des cas, indifférents.
Le dégoût est rare en comparaison,
et même lorsque les gens sont dégoûtés et horrifiés,
cela ne les empêche pas toujours de venir tout de même pour regarder.
Peut-être que l'exemple le plus frappant
de la capacité humaine à regarder une décapitation et rester indifférent,
voire à être déçu,
était l'introduction en France de la guillotine en 1792,
cette célèbre machine à décapiter.
Pour nous au XXIème siècle,
la guillotine peut sembler être une machine monstrueuse,
mais pour les premières foules à l'avoir vue, c'était une déception.
Elles étaient habituées à voir de longues et pénibles exécutions sur l'échafaud
où les gens étaient mutilés, brûlés et lentement démembrés.
Pour eux, voir la guillotine en action,
c'était si rapide, il n'y avait rien à voir.
La lame tombait, la tête était tranchée,
sortant immédiatement du champ de vision,
et ils criaient :
« Rendez-nous la potence, rendez-nous la potence en bois. »
La fin des exécutions publiques en Europe et en Amérique
tenait en partie de la volonté de se montrer plus humain envers les criminels,
mais c'était également en partie
car la foule refusait obstinément de se comporter
comme elle aurait dû.
Trop souvent, le jour d'une exécution
ressemblait plus à un carnaval qu'à une cérémonie solennelle.
Aujourd'hui, une exécution judiciaire publique est impensable
en Europe ou en Amérique,
mais il y a d'autres scénarios qui devraient nous faire réfléchir
sur le fait que les choses sont différentes
et que nous n'agissons plus ainsi.
Prenez par exemple les incidents d'incitation au suicide.
C'est lorsqu'une foule se réunit
pour regarder une personne qui est grimpée en haut d'un bâtiment public
dans le but de se suicider,
et les gens dans la foule crient et huent :
« Termines-en ! Allez, saute ! »
C'est un phénomène connu.
En 1981, un rapport révélait que dans 10 tentatives de suicide sur 21,
il y avait des incidents d'incitation au suicide et de railleries par la foule.
Et il y a eu des incidents décrits dans la presse cette année.
Cet incident était fréquemment signalé
à Telford et Shropshire en mars de cette année.
Et quand cela se produit aujourd'hui,
les gens prennent des photos et des vidéos sur leurs téléphones
et ils les publient sur Internet.
Quand il s'agit de meurtriers brutaux qui postent les vidéos de leur décapitation,
Internet a créé un nouveau type de foule.
Aujourd'hui, l'action a lieu dans un endroit et à moment différents,
ce qui donne au spectateur une impression de détachement, de séparation
de ce qu'il se passe.
Cela n'a rien à voir avec moi.
Cela s'est déjà produit.
Nous avons également une impression d'intimité sans précédent.
Aujourd'hui, on nous offre aussi les places du premier rang.
Nous pouvons tous regarder en privé, où et quand nous voulons,
et personne n'a jamais besoin de savoir que nous avons cliqué.
Cette impression de séparation --
des autres personnes, de l'événement lui-même --
semble être la clé de la compréhension de notre capacité à regarder,
et Internet crée
une impression de détachement de plusieurs façons,
ce qui semble éroder la responsabilité morale individuelle.
Nos activités en ligne sont souvent différentes de celle de la vie réelle,
comme si ce que nous faisions en ligne était d'une façon moins réel.
Nous nous sentons moins responsables de nos actions
quand nous interagissons en ligne.
Il y a une impression d'anonymat, d'invisibilité,
donc nous nous sentons moins responsables de notre comportement.
Internet rend également plus facile de tomber sur des choses par inadvertance,
des choses que nous aurions tendance à éviter dans notre vie quotidienne.
Une vidéo peut se lancer avant même que vous sachiez ce que vous regardez.
Ou vous pourriez être tenté de regarder une chose que vous ne regarderiez pas
dans votre vie quotidienne ou si vous étiez avec d'autres personnes.
Quand l'action est pré-enregistrée,
et a lieu à un autre endroit, à un autre moment,
regarder semble être une activité passive.
Je ne peux rien y faire maintenant.
Cela s'est déjà produit.
Toutes ces choses rendent plus facile pour nous, utilisateurs d'internet
de nous laisser gagner par notre curiosité sur la mort,
de repousser nos limites personnelles,
de tester et d'explorer notre sentiment de choc.
Mais regarder n'est pas passif.
Au contraire, nous satisfaisons le désir du meurtrier d'être vu.
Quand la victime d'une décapitation est attachée et sans défense,
il ou elle devient essentiellement un pion dans le spectacle du meurtrier.
Contrairement à un tête prise en trophée lors d'une bataille,
qui représente la chance et la compétence nécessaires pour gagner un combat,
quand une décapitation est mise en scène,
quand il s'agit essentiellement d'une pièce de théâtre,
le pouvoir vient de l'accueil que reçoit le meurtrier pendant sa performance.
En d'autres mots, regarder est vraiment une partie de l'événement.
L'événement n'a plus lieu à un seul endroit
à un moment précis comme c'était le cas et comme il semblerait toujours.
Maintenant l'événement est étiré dans le temps et l'espace,
et toute personne qui regarde joue un rôle.
Nous devrions arrêter de regarder,
mais nous savons que nous ne le ferons pas.
L'histoire dit que nous ne le ferons pas,
et les meurtriers le savent aussi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Merci. Je vais reprendre ceci. Merci.
Pendant qu'ils préparent la prochaine intervention,
je veux vous poser la question que beaucoup doivent se poser
et qui est : comment vous êtes-vous intéressée à ce sujet ?
Frances Larson : je travaillais dans un musée
appelé le Musée de Pitt Rivers à Oxford,
qui était célèbre pour son exposition de têtes réduites de l'Amérique du Sud.
Les gens disaient : « Le musée des têtes réduites, le musée des têtes réduites ! »
Et à ce moment-là, je travaillais sur l'histoire
des collections scientifiques de crânes.
Je travaillais sur les collections de crânes,
et il m'a semblé ironique
qu'il y ait des gens venant voir cette culture gore, primitive et sauvage,
qu'ils en fantasmaient presque
sans même réellement comprendre ce qu'ils voyaient,
et que pendant ce temps ces vastes -- des centaines de milliers
de crânes dans nos musées à travers l'Europe et les États-Unis --
soutenaient cette poursuite édifiante de rationalité scientifique.
Donc je voulais en quelque sorte retourner cela et dire : « Regardons-nous. »
Nous regardons ces têtes réduites à travers la vitrine.
Regardons notre propre histoire et notre fascination culturelle pour ces choses.
BG : Merci de l'avoir partagé.
FL : Merci.
(Applaudissements)